we are set for baseball at yankee
stadium it actually never rained but a
45-minute hour delay to get us going
with a great matchup well that dominant
performance for coal against houston
came with the context of some struggles
before that he had a
era in his previous six starts and i'm
sure the yankees are hoping he could
dominate one more time because their
offense is not quite healthy as
hernandez climbs in off we go with
hernandez ripping one down the line he
holmen on the first pitch against cole
at fenway park he doubles on the first
pitch here
great start for the red sox so quickly a
runner in scoring position for alex
verdugo verdugo lofts one down the line
to left locastro moves into the corner
in a tight spot makes a leaping play
what a catch a leaping catch against the
sidewall in foul territory near the
polls highlight play here in the first
inning here's jd martinez trying to
bring hernandez in from third slider way
outside did he go he went first base
umpire manny gonzalez rang him up oh
there's the big strikeout now two outs
and a run over a third and here's left
hand hitting rafael devers
struck him out swinging high fastball a
pole strikes out two the red sox leave a
man at third and a tough customer for
them to face off with the first time
all-star nathan ivaldi yeah big
right-hander strong right-hander comes
downhill right at you with a quadrant of
pitches and here's dj le mayhew another
0-2
and a
pop slide down the line to right renfro
coming on
to make the catch
so the mayhew retired and here is
stanton breaks one off buckling the
knees of stanton for out number two out
of the break for stanton i don't believe
he's put the ball in play yet
he looks sharp to start the game two
quick outs here the yankee first vincent
vivaldi just five batters all season 103
innings coming in he hits back-to-back
hitters and it sets up a two-out chance
for gleber torres they haven't all yet
been able to really muster up that big
hit fly ball to right routine play
renfro a couple of steps back and he
makes the catch
and vivaldi hits two in the yankees
strand both of them timo castro out of
the game after he came up limp after
that leaping catch and left so tyler
wade comes in yet another yankee down
with an injury it'll be hunter renfro
against garrett cole got him to chase
his third consecutive k one gone and
here comes jared duran for his first
major league at bat red sox seventh
round pick in 2018 out of long beach
state so he makes his debut here on the
first pitch that he sees as a big leader
he rips a basement in the center his dad
octavio his mom dina other family
members in attendance you made it to the
majors amazing you're facing garrett
cole and you're banging a line driving
the first pitch that you see what a
moment for duran
runner in scoring position in both
innings so far for the red sox this time
with two gone for christian arroyo
his first big league run on a two-out
base hit from christian arroyo and the
red sox lead coal in the yankees one
nothing here cole gave up three hits in
the complete game shutout against
houston he gave up three hits the first
time through the order here tonight
struck him out swinging high fastball up
he went up the ladder and that is
strikeout number four for garrett struck
him out swinging anders takes his helmet
up and bounces it at home blade
five strikeouts now for coal a couple
scoreless innings in the bank for nathan
ivaldi craig allen batting first here
swings and misses at an inside fastball
to tied him up at 97. and he's a
strikeout victim that's the third for
nate and it brings up lemay you will
pass ball strike three call the high
fastball strikeout number four for
avaldi three four and five for the
yankees looking for their first hit
against nathan vivaldi it's on the
corner to get outdoor looking strikeout
number five for nathan navalny one going
in the fourth three two sanchez swings
and misses
two up two down here in the fourth on
back-to-back caves for evaldi swinging
to miss it a high fast ball and down he
goes seven punch-outs he strikes out
three of the fourth and it's been a
pitchers duel as you might expect
between these two talented right-handers
garrett cole and nathan of aldi 2-2
pitch he swings and misses
half-heartedly strikeout number seven
for cole he's got back-to-back case to
open the fifth
continuing to rack him off his eighth
total tonight
swung on and driven to deep right center
field
that back at the wall is wade who jumps
and he made the catch wow
he made the catch on top of the
auxiliary scoreboard wall as we go to
the bottom of the fifth nathan avaldi
yet to allow a hit for the struggling
yankees offense which brings up the
bottom of the order well two down here's
greg allen turned around to right center
field towards the gap for the first hit
of the game for the yankees
and comes from greg
now this is the hitter you want up if
you're the yankees if they're going to
get any chance to drive in a run it's
going to be this guy
in le mayo
allen will score
and the yankees tie the game at one base
is loaded two gone in a tie game in the
six walks
renfro with an enfield single
duran with the wall against garrett cole
to load him up and here is christian
vasquez they're giving up just two hits
with a man in scoring position and two
out all year coming into the night a
slider
gets him
and calls out of the jam keeping the
game tied
and there's some
discussion right now going on between
alex verdugo and left field and some of
the fans to the point where the game is
being delayed yeah they threw a ball at
him i think he just said i got hit in
the back with the ball so with a ball
yep and now everybody's leaving the
field he's into going back and forth
with the fans if it's just conversation
but a line crossed here whether it hit
him or not going back to left field now
this had a little bit of everything this
last half hour or so here's gary sanchez
it's two for 32 in july after the
monster june
sanchez going back
and the yankees take the lead
at the home run from sanchez and up
comes
[Applause]
gary sanchez and gleber torres hit home
runs back to back middle belly to belly
and the yankees take a 3-1 lead
they went out there to start this inning
and garrett cole came out of the dugout
he was ready to i was shocked
unbelievable it's been
40 minutes since his last pitch and
finally the tarp
it's pulled the game has been called the
yankees have won this ball game by the
final of three to one